a young and beautiful angel whose life
ended way too soon the words of those
who knew nine-year-old lilia valutite
stabbed and killed in her hometown of
boston
outside shops and offices on this quiet
street lilia lay dead even before police
arrived
officers were called to the scene of an
incident at fountain lane around 6 20 pm
yesterday
a nine-year-old girl has sadly died as a
result of what we believe to be a stab
wound
we've arrested two people in connection
with the incident
lincolnshire police called this an
isolated incident but were reluctant to
confirm who had been arrested and for
what specific reason
as they deployed extra officers
throughout the day forensic teams
carried out extensive searches for
evidence to piece together what happened
here on thursday evening
for those who knew lilia and her family
this shock death is devastating
eurate is a friend of the family but
also leads the boston lithuanian
community group
nobody deserves such end of their life
especially a small young beautiful angel
who had lots of lots of you know ideas
how to live she she danced she sang she
she was really lovely girl and i can't
believe that such things can happen in
our town
she says many families are now worried
to let their children outside of course
i'm scared i'm scared i'm worried i'm
worried about
any people who live in the town about
children about adults you know in the
town center when when it is
even not not night when when lots of
people in so so how we can feel of
course we
feel vulnerable
because we don't give get any support
this is a town now rocked by yesterday's
killing many here are struggling to come
to terms with the death of an innocent
girl stabbed in broad daylight and as
the murder investigation continues
so do the tributes
but flowers and words will be little
consolation to the family of
nine-year-old lilia whose life was cut
so short in zaman rashid sky news in
boston